The answer is 0.27.
We first consider the possibility we have actually have cancer, in which our tests
will give us a positive result of 0.9 chance, and then we add the possibility of not having cancer
that's 1-0.1 or 0.9, and then when one gives us a positive result with 0.2 chance or 1-0.8.
Resolving this gives us something like this that is 0.09+0.18 adds up to 0.27.
So now, I want you to write the computer code that accepts arbitrary P₀, P₁, P₂
and calculates the resulting probability of a positive test result and here's my answer.
My code does exactly what I have shown you before.
It first considers the possibility of cancer multiply this with the test sensitivity P₁ and then it absorbs
the opposite possibility, and of course, the specificity over here refers to a negative test results,
so we take 1 minus that to get the +1.
Adding these two parts up give us the desired results so let's try this.
Here's my function f with the prime that we just assumed, and if I hit, run I get 0.27.
Obviously, I can change the prime with this.
So suppose we make it much less likely to have cancer in the prior from 0.1 to 0.01
then my 0.27 changes to 0.207.
Now realize it is not the posterior in Bayes' rule. This is just the probability of getting a positive test result.
You can see this if you change the prior probability of cancer to zero,
which means we don't have cancer no matter what the test result says,
but there's 0.2 chance of getting a positive test result,
and the reason is our test has a specificity of 0.8 that is even in the absence of cancer,
there's 0.2 chance of getting a positive test result.